Hey, this is Matt Ganzac and in this
video we are going over the AI software
blueprint. Creating prototypes in days,
not months, leveraging AI. First, a
little disclaimer we have to get out of
the way. Just by watching this video,
you are not guaranteed success by
implementing this training. You are not
guaranteed success. Results are not
always typical and nine out of 10en
software ventures fail in the first 18
months. According to Forbes.com,
business is risky. Always consult your
attorney and your accountant. All case
studies are true to the best of my
knowledge. Don't purchase anything from
me if you cannot afford it. Starting a
business is an investment and it takes
time. Software is not a get-richqu
scheme. Okay? It was all a dream. I
won't do any impersonations or anything,
but I built my first software platform
in 2006 and it sucked. But I'm pretty
sure it's still online today, exactly
how I originally built it in 2006. So
that must say something, right? I still
think it
sucked. Between 2008 and 2015, I worked
for one of the top 100 most visited
apps. Um, later on, like 2013, 2014, I
think we dropped to like top 500. But
when I got started in 2008, we built up
to be one of the most 100 most visited
websites, which is insane. like millions
and millions and millions and millions
of visitors every single day. It was
nuts. Since then, I've been launching
new software platforms and I never
dreamt in my wildest dreams that AI
would be writing software and writing
code. It's absolutely insane. Today, you
can get a software platform online in
days, not months. And the time to strike
is now, not tomorrow. The speed of which
if you're sitting on an idea right now,
the speed of which people are moving on
your ideas is insane. Like I can have an
idea in the morning by lunch I can have
it all validated and smoke test and
whatnot and by the end of the day I can
have it live people are using it. It's
insane. In a single day it's nuts. So
you need to get moving on this. Now, all
of this starts with a problem. All too
often, too many people think about way
too many things. And the only thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning
steps of your software venture, SAS,
app, whatever you want to call it, is a
problem. Solving a problem is essential
to successful software businesses.
Starting with the problem, you are
solving. Period. End of story.
Everything else is just trying to solve
the problem, but focus on the problem. I
cannot reiterate like people reach out
to me. Oh, I got this great idea. I
secured the domain and I have the
trademark pending and D and we got to do
this. We got to move on this. Well, what
problem are you solving? Problem? I just
have a great name. I bought a great
domain. We should build a product around
it. It's going to fail. That venture is
going to fail. I can guarantee you out
of the, you know, one out of 10
businesses that succeed, they're
focusing on the problem. Do not focus on
making money. That is not a problem.
Like your bank account reading very
little amount of money is not the
problem. It is not the problem. The
problem needs to be other people's bank
accounts that have money that are
willing to pay to solve a problem.
That's how you solve things. Money comes
after you solve the problem. You are
paid in direct proportion to the
difficulty of the problems you solve.
That's Elon Musk. I would listen to that
guy. He uh definitely knows what he's
talking about. I wrote a book in 2016. I
mentioned him several times. I've
always, you know, looked at the things
that he's built and the problems that
he's solved and the things that he's
tried to tackle. Regardless of what you
think of him, I think that it's insane.
I think it's insane. And I think that
going forward in thinking like people
like Elon Musk or thinking like you know
Richard Branson or thinking about things
in the way that other people that have
been very successful in solving problems
the way they think that's the way we
need to think that's how we need to move
so let's solve a problem we use chat
GPT03 to research problems chat GPT03 is
the model that uses reasoning the some
of the other models that are out there
are not using reasoning. And if you're
watching this years down the road and
they've updated, the key thing is we
want the advanced reasoning. We want it
to think. We just don't want it to read
the internet and just spit things back
out to us. We want it to read things on
the internet, analyze it, use reasoning,
and then give a response back. Uh I just
don't want things just spit out from the
internet. Right? So currently as I'm
making this video, chat GP03 is the
model that uses advanced reasoning. If
you do not have a problem worth solving
in your mind right now, use this prompt.
Give me 10 businesses and industries
that have huge problems that could be
solved using AI and they would be
willing to pay for these solutions. So,
if you don't want just 10 businesses,
you have a specific business that you
want to work on, just replace 10
businesses with give me 10 problems that
are worth solving in X business. So, you
can edit that prompt a little bit based
upon what you have. But if you have no
idea, you're starting at absolutely no
idea, you just know that you want to be
in the software business because it does
have great margins because you can have
great exits and you can make good money
from it if you do things correctly and
be part of that 10% of success. You can
be successful with it. But the key thing
is you need to ask it the right
questions. So let's review these
together. Okay, so I asked a question,
give me 10 businesses and industries
that have huge problems that could be
solved using AI and they would be
willing to pay for those. So it thinks
about it and it's like uh below or 10
gap analysis targets. Um number one,
hospital revenue, right? Um property and
casualty insurers. I'm actually building
software for I've already built it.
We're to market. were um valued at an
eight figureure company already and um I
literally did this one and I did this
one too. So this one's in development.
But point is like this is exactly how I
realize the opportunities that are out
there. So go find them. Go research. You
know, you can respond give me 10 more.
Like you can literally talk to this.
It'll respond back. It'll be smart.
It'll come up with ideas. It'll use some
reasoning, come up with some ideas and
so forth. Drill down, have a whole
conversation about it, and you're just
drilling down and trying to find
problems and solutions, and you can
develop those solutions. So, all too
often, people look at, you know, what
are the top 10 highest grossing software
businesses? Make me uh, you know,
duplicate. You know, I want to compete
with Mailchimp, for example. That's a
terrible way of going about this. You
are going to fail if you do that. Like
you have to look at problems that are
out there that are not currently solved.
If you're saying Mailchimp is too
expensive, I could build something that
you know is far less expensive and
people will switch from Mailchimp to me.
They will not. They will not. They will
not. Like it's a total waste of time and
you're going to waste money. You're
going to waste time. You're going to
waste your resources. is you're going to
waste everything trying to just rebuild
Mailchimp. It's a total waste of time.
Or the other idea is, well, you know, I
use this app for this and I use this app
for this and I use this app for this.
That should all be in one. Again,
terrible idea. It's a terrible idea
because you not only said you want to
recreate one app, but you want to
recreate three, four, five different
apps. All the features that are in all
these different apps and consolidated
into one. So companies are paying for,
you know, product A, product B, product
C, product D, and it's all integrated.
It's all working and, you know, they're
using it. Why would you try to compete
with four different products? That's
like you going and fighting four
different fights at the same time. It's
a terrible idea. It's a terrible waste
of time. So, the point is use this and
validate the idea. Come up with what it
is that you're solving, the problem
you're solving, and then from there,
like look at this thing. Like, it's
thinking. It's coming up with all these
different ideas. Here's some things.
Here's some things you can do, and
here's why they'll pay for it. So use
this brainstorm like instead of just
scrolling on Instagram or YouTube or
wherever Tik Tok you're scrolling open
up Chat GPT download it on your phone
switch over to the 03 model and ask it
questions just talk to it in the middle
of night when I can't fall asleep I'll
just open chat GPT and just brainstorm
and just come up with ideas. And this is
the best use of time when you have
downtime. It's not scrolling through
your, you know, feed just mindless. It's
brainstorming. It's coming up with
ideas. It's thinking about things. It's,
you know, challenging. So, you could
take one of these ideas like this idea
and you could challenge chat GPT. Like,
I don't think that this really is that
big of an opportunity. please explain
that opportunity scale to me a little
bit more so I better understand it and
it can drill down and and then you can
argue with it like this is the best
thing and then you could say long haul
trucking fleets and 3PL's
um I want to take this on but tell me
all the reasons why this is a bad idea
and it'll tell you what are the biggest
challenges that I'm going to face when
trying to you know take this on what are
some of the big challenges I'm going to
face here. What are the some of the big
challenges I'm going to face here? Like
ask it questions. Right? So often times
in in looking at these, you don't have a
ton of people to sell to, right? But if
they all have this problem that you're
trying to solve and they're willing to
pay for it and they're willing the the
problem cost them a lot of money, they
might be willing to pay a lot of money
for the service. So instead of having,
you know, one or two, you know, people
signing up per day at 30 bucks a month,
you could have one signing up every
quarter and they're paying you half
million to a million dollars a year per
client, per deal. Really makes a
difference as you can, you know, as you
can see here. Okay. So next, you have an
idea like you've done your research.
Let's just fast forward and say you've
done all this research and you feel
really good about something. What is a
good next step? If you do not want to go
at this alone, partner with somebody who
is an expert in that field. Somebody
that maybe works in the field, somebody
that has the problem, maybe a company
that's willing to pay for the software
development and then want to partner on
selling it to their competitors,
whatever. Be creative, come up with
ideas. And also another idea is perhaps
to attract partners, you could create
content talking about solutions and
talking about how you can create
solutions that you can create apps in
days, not months. You could create
content, put it out there and make a
call to action like if you're having a
problem in your current business and you
want to solve it with tech, message me
and let's talk about how we can solve
problems together. So, if you don't want
to go at this alone, then that's fine.
If you do want to go at this alone, then
do it. That's fine, too. But I found
that partnering in ventures, like I
said, I have a doctor. We're building
hospital software. I have a restaurant
owner. We're building restaurant
software. I have a sales professional.
We're building sales software. Um, when
you partner with people that are already
in the field, that already have the
problem, that already have people to
sell to and have the capital to put up
to do it, it really brings that capital,
knowledge, and connections all to the
table, which can really fast forward
your venture and the successes of your
venture is directly tied to those three
assets. So otherwise, you're looking for
the capital yourself, you're looking for
the knowledge yourself, and you're
looking for the connections yourself.
So, I like partnering with people, but
again, that's totally up to you. I like
asking experts what their problems are
facing and brainstorming ideas. So, if
you are going at this alone, you can
always do that and gain knowledge and
capital and so forth. Maybe give them
some equity in the deal. Structure a
deal, make it make sense, but know these
three assets, capital, knowledge, and
connections are essential to having a
successful software business. again use
chatb03 to come up with solutions to
these problems. So we go in there, we
focus on the problem solution, the
avatar and the TAM. So we're going to
talk about each one of those. We're
going to break those all down. Um first
ideal customer profile, ICP. Don't try
to reach everyone with what it is that
you're doing. Focus on a core customer
needs. For example, like I said, we're
building software for salespeople. We
niched down. We didn't say every
salesperson in the world, there are 5
million salespeople in the United States
alone and every single one could use our
software. No, we niche down. We say what
is my partner? What is your direct need?
He tells me and I said okay, what do we
need to build in order to make this
successful for you? Now, who else has
the specific problems that you have that
would be willing to pay for this? that
is kind of similar to what you're doing.
So, we picked two other verticals that
are so similar that the app doesn't need
to change. It can be one app. It doesn't
change. We don't have like complex
features to try to reach every
salesperson. We're focusing on people
that do high ticket sales. So, we niche
down to people that do high ticket
sales. Period. End of story. Right? Find
out what they are doing now to solve
their problem. So go do some research on
those people. Ask them questions like,
"Hey, what do you use now to solve XYZ
problem?" So now you kind of know what
your problem is. You kind of know who
your customer is. Interview a few other
people in that market and ask them the
question, what are you doing to solve
this problem? Now then do some research
on those competitors and ask them, hey,
are you using X software? X software. X
software. No, I'm not. Okay. Why don't
you use XYZ software for this problem?
Is it cost? Is it ease of use? Is it
lack of features? Or did you just not
know about that other software? If you
didn't know about it, then the problem
might not be big enough to search for a
solution in order to solve that problem.
So therefore, the problem might not
actually be big enough than what it is
that you're making it out to be in your
mind. So this is such an essential slide
in this entire process and by far one of
the most overlooked slides. So maybe you
thought about the problem, you thought
about the solution and and then you go
right to development. You go right to
hey, I need to hire somebody. We need to
start working and blah blah blah blah
blah blah blah. Skipping all these
essential steps along the way. But this
one slide could have saved you months
allowed you to pivot to a different
idea. And in those 3 months that you're
struggling to build something that no
one wants, you could otherwise be
working on something that people do
want, that you're solving a problem,
gets you closer to money faster, closer
to revenue faster, and really closes the
gap on what it takes to be successful in
software, right? So, if these answers
tell you what you need to know and if
it's successful, you should build the
solution. So answer those questions.
Period. End of story. If you're not
interviewing people, if you're not
willing to interview people, you
shouldn't get in the software business
because you need to understand if the
problem is actually worth solving. Do
that first. Tam
Sam, what does it mean? Why is it
important? Why should you care? Total
addressable market. That's TAM. So, like
I said, 5 million salespeople in the
United States. I don't know how many
sales people there are. 20 million
salespeople coming out of the womb
selling something like I don't know, but
that's total addressable market. So,
take your ICP and put it into chat GPT
and ask what the total addressable
market for a problem that you're solving
to an ICP. What is a total addressable
market? Next one is serviceable
addressable market like if they're
already paying for something total is
everybody and then serviceable is
they're paying for your competitors and
then your share of the market is the
smallest number. So if we say 100% is
total, serviceable is maybe 30%, 40%
that are paying for something else and
share of the market maybe you can
capture a fraction of a percent of that
marketplace and that would be your share
of market. Make sense? Again, chat GP03
breaks all this down for you and then
from there you can plug in what people
would be willing to pay for it. You can
start building out some financial models
of what you could potentially do in your
share of the market share. You can tell
chatb03 to be aggressive. You can tell
it to be conservative. You can tell it
to give you low-end numbers. You can
tell it whatever you want to create your
projections. But you could basically
build projections based upon TAM, SAM,
and SAM.
Cool. All right. So what somebody is
willing to pay for an app interview
people and say if I solve this problem
would you be willing to pay X is that
worth it to you and you need to
understand that what is the value that
you're bringing with the solution again
we're building we have we have software
for hospitals and um some of our tickets
are quite high in the millions but the
problem that we're solving is well
beyond ond what it is that we are
offering. In some cases, uh we actually
built a um uh return on investment
calculator on our website. And in some
cases, some of the people that we've
gotten started with have 600% ROI even
at spending millions of dollars using
our software. So, take that in
consideration. See if people are willing
to pay for the solution. Build a landing
page. get people willing to pay for it.
Validate your idea before you start
building your idea. So, not only do we
interview people, but I'll actually put
up a landing page and validate to see if
people would actually pay for it. Either
getting them to opt in for a wait list
or actually pay for something and call
it a pre-sale product or just refund
them and say, "Hey, it's not ready yet.
I'll let you know when it is." All this
is covered in great detail in our
ideation course at macanzac.com, by the
way. So I go through this. Every single
one of these slides is an entire video
with additional insights and steps and
walkthroughs and so forth. This would be
a 8 hour video if I just record this all
together. So everything's over in
macans.com. You can go check it out.
Building your prototype in days, not
months. Once you build out your entire
plan, put this into
chatg03. You are an expert developer.
Build me a plan on how to create a
prototype that solves fill-in- thelank
for ICP fill-in- thelank using Replet. I
love Replet. I've been very successful
with it. I've used like eight different
AI building apps and I think Replet is
putting out the best results personally.
So, that's the one I'm using, but I put
it in quotations. If you use something
else, you use something else. Whatever.
Use the same format. If you are an
expert developer, build me a plan of how
to create a prototype that solves
problem for ICP using platform in days,
not months. That's key because the first
thing it's going to build out for you is
some 6 to 12 month plan, but then you
say in days, not months. Then it starts
really bringing down to get a prototype
online and it starts refining that plan.
From there, you can further refine the
plan by responding back and saying,
"Hey, that's not quite the feature that
I had in mind. That's not quite the
thing that I had in mind. Add this, take
that away, do this, do that." Have a
conversation with ChatGpt back and forth
to really refine that plan. Once you
have your plan together, use chat GP03
and put this in. Using the plan above,
or you can copy and paste the plan in,
whatever. using a plan above, build me a
replet or whichever platform you're
using, a replet prompt to start the
development of this app to build the
prototype in days, not months. Again, I
tell it really fast. I'm not trying to
be over complicated with this. it could
find opportunities to not necessarily
shortcut but you know kind of omit some
features like hey maybe we shouldn't do
this piece yet just for the prototype or
hey maybe we should use a third party
connection for this instead of doing it
this way it's a great way to make chat
GPT reason and come up with faster
prototype delivery so that's a really
key essential here okay prompting and
replet After you add the promplet into
Replet, it will start building the
prototype and this is free to get
started. I think I pay like 50 75 bucks
a month now, whatever I'm paying them.
Um, but I've built so many different
things and we're hosting and or
whatever, doing so many things through
the platform. But getting started, it's
free. There could be some errors on
screen as it starts kicking it out. When
they come up, just copy the error, feed
it right back into Replet. After an hour
or so, you should have an app that you
can click through and you can start
messing with and you can drill down. But
if errors are persistent, go back to
chat GPTO3, take the error, put it in
there, and ask chat GPTO3 for how to fix
that bug in Replet, and it'll give you a
better prompt to respond back to Replet.
So, really smart thing. Um, I'll take
you through one of my Replet builds.
Let's do it. Okay, so this is one of my
Replet builds, and I pasted in to get
started. exactly what came from chatb3.
It said exactly what it is that I'm
building. It gives this full kick out
and I just copied and pasted it directly
in. No editing at all. It just totally
just kicked it out. So, it started
thinking and uh let's look at the
timestamps. So, uh 10:06 a.m. on April
21st, I started working on it. So, it's
kicking it out and it builds this thing
and it looks terrible, but it's a
website, right? And that took how long?
That took
uh what was it? 06. So, it took 20
minutes, less than 20 minutes, like 15
minutes, whatever it is. Um, and then I
was like, "Hey, here's my logo, here's
my contact information, here's, you
know, my social media information. Go
ahead and update that." So, I just gave
it back and it updates some things.
uh going through when the logo is on a
dark background. Use this version. Okay.
Updated. Um also it started looking a
little bit better because I prompted it
to uh what was that prompt? Uh design
the landing page to look more like a
billion-dollar software company. So it
took that literally and it said
developing billion-dollar technology.
That's really not what I wanted to say,
but whatever. Let's just keep going. Uh
the header starts scrolling down. it
needs to use dark etc. you know just
kind of giving it some natural you know
verbiage. Uh remove the section where
product projects launched uh partner
with industry leaders go ahead and add
those. So yeah point is just flowing
through this thing just you know talking
to it asking questions talking. It's
11-1ven. It's been 1 hour. I mean I got
something pretty decent. I mean, I could
literally go live with something like
this, but I I want to refine it a little
bit more. I keep going. Now, it looks
good. Let's work on the dashboard, etc.
So, it starts kicking out some more
things for
me. And we just go and go and, you know,
it creates a uh login
authentication, and it just keeps going
down. We just keep uh so error on
dashboard, page, runtime, whatever, it
starts fixing it. So yeah, just
scrolling down, you know, just going
through it. Um 108. So it started at
10:06, it's 108. I probably took a break
for lunch. Um I don't know what I was
doing. Like probably took a couple phone
calls, let it kind of run, do something
else, multitask,
etc. Uh, so now I'm drilling down a
little bit further, like this needs to
do this, this needs to do that, and I'm
just feeding in the URLs to tell it what
it needs to do. Uh, it's starting to
create, uh, some pages here. Um, so
that's inside a membership area. And
really what this app does, it allows
people to go to the app and kind of
validate your idea, kind of talk about
your idea, talk about what you're trying
to solve, and then you can literally
connect with my developers. They'll help
you answer questions, move along the
process, etc. If you want to hire us to
do something that's kind of complicated,
you can hire us right inside the app.
We'll work for hourly rate in order to
deliver the results, etc. So I wanted to
have an app an easy way that I can
manage all my projects all from one
place. So the problem I was solving all
my communication is so disjointed for my
business. I need to have a single place
where I can do all of my work and have
my developers communicate and me
communicate and we can work through and
develop projects very easily. a really
easy onboarding process for new
business. And I needed something complex
but simple. And that was essentially
what it is that uh Replet built for me
was an app that is really simple to
manage projects and um you know get
things moving along and have a nice
onboarding wizard and all those other
things. Um so yeah, fixing a login page,
fixing more things. Uh let's see where
we're at. Uh 728. So, at this point, go
and pick my kids up, you know, come
home, make dinner, get back on, prompt
it a couple more times. There's probably
a bedtime in here. Um, probably put them
to bed, and then working on a little bit
more. Uh, started working on confetti. I
don't know why I was working on
confetti, but 9:32. So, I started at
10:06 and I deployed the app at 9:32. So
that's what less than 12 hours I had an
app ready to go live that solved a huge
problem for me and it looks great like
up it's awesome like what could have
been developed for this in 12 hours. I I
you know put the video placeholder there
but literally 12 hours built something
that was a serious problem for me. I was
able to build this in hours, not weeks,
not months, hours. It It's absolutely
insane. So, I love this app. I love
building web apps with this app. It
doesn't really make native iOS apps, but
you could still build your prototype on
a web base and then give it over to a
developer to then turn it into a React
iOS app if you want uh an app to be
delivered on phones. But point is
prototype here easy. Took me less than
12 hours. Prototype done. Period. People
could be signing up less than 12 hours
later. So let's hop back to the slides.
Okay, so you have your prototype built.
Again, took less than 12 hours to build
that app. If everything is working, you
could publish it right through Replet.
If you need assistance with deploying,
you can contact me, message me,
whatever. Let's talk about it. Or go
hire somebody on Upwork. Get the bugs
all sorted out, get your security all
buttoned up, and then get a few beta
testers on board, test the prototype,
fix the bugs as they start sharing those
bugs with you. Then you can start
improving the UI, which is called user
interface. That's basically the design
and so forth, and the user experience
like, hey, when I click on this, it
should go to a wizard and not go to, you
know, some long form. It should be a
step-by-step wizard. Whatever, whatever
bugs or ideas they bring you. You could
kind of take that and just kind of plan
out how to fix that. Now, you have a
working prototype. It's live. You could
literally have something that people are
using and they're giving you feedback
on. Congratulations. I mean, you're
pre-revenue, but you're in business and
it could be a couple hours. Sales
commitments. This is the next big step.
Again, this is something that I don't
see people too often doing, but it's so
essential. So, at this point, your app
might not have billing integration, like
the one I showed you did no billing
integration. Okay, that's fine. get
written commitments, non-binding
agreements from companies, people that
would be willing to use that technology
either in their business if you're
deploying a white label solution or if
it's a you know billing type thing that
um you know they would pay for access to
the software then get commitments. If I
built this out in the next 6 months
would you be willing to pay for it? Yes
or no? be transparent with those
timelines and go to live in production
and try to get at least 100,000 to
200,000 in annual recurring revenue
commitments. It's a pretty big job to do
that, but like I said, if you're solving
big enough problems with your
technology, you should be able to get
that from just a couple clients for them
to say, "Yeah, if you could solve this,
I would go ahead and pay for it because
my problem is worth far more than 50,000
or $100,000 a year. my problem is worth
$500,000 a year and time and money and
all all those things and then all your
other features become those ancillary
benefits that you're adding in. Take
those commitments and then let's go
raise some capital. That's it. So, how
fast can this
happen? How fast can it how fast can you
get through this? So, example, a friend
of mine uh sales guy says, "Hey, come
have coffee with me." It was a Friday
morning. I had coffee with him and he
pitched me his idea and I was like,
"Wow, that's insane." I came home, did
the research on Chat GPT and I was like,
"Uh, I'm building this. This is this is
awesome. I'm building it." So,
literally, I had the prototype by that
night, uh, coffee in the morning,
prototype at night. I had it on, uh,
sales professionals phones that weekend.
I send it over to him. He starts using
it. All these sales pros start using it.
And then they start saying, "Hey, if
this could connect to my CRM and then
call things up from my CRM, that would
be amazing. Could you do that?" Yeah,
cool. Yeah, I can do that. It's a great
idea. Right. So, we start working
through the features and working through
the things of which they start asking
for and then we start getting some
commitments and we're raising capital on
a $10 million valuation. That's it.
Raising capital. Ask chat GPT03 what a
fair market valuation would be for your
product. Again, total addressable
market, what people are willing to pay
for it. Feed it in that information if
it doesn't already have it and let it
base your valuation based upon also
those commitment letters that you have.
Again, before taking any next steps in
raising capital or anything like that,
consult your attorney before taking
these next steps. just to give you an
understanding of what the next steps
are. Not to say that you should circumn
your attorney. You should always talk to
your attorney about raising capital.
There's so many, you know, different
nuances of raising capital that need to
be handled by an attorney and I am not
an attorney. So therefore, I cannot give
you legal advice. However, the best
legal advice I can give you is consult
an attorney who is authorized and
accredited and has all those things to
give you legal advice. Cool. Do that.
But for knowledge
purposes, it would be a safe round. That
is a great way to proceed forward. So,
you can ask your attorney what a safe
note is. It is a simple agreement for
future equity. That's what SAFE stands
for. Do some research yourself. Ask Chat
GPT, whatever. Ask your attorney if you
should offer discounts on future rounds.
Talk about it. Talk to Chhat GPT. Talk
to your attorney. Figure it out. So, I
like using Chat GPT to research and you
can research what a safe note is to see
if it would be a good solution for you
to raise money on a safe note. However,
I can tell you that a lot of investors
do like safe notes and you can look into
that. Again, consult an attorney. I
don't know how much many times I need to
say that. You need to talk to an
attorney when you're raising money.
Period. So, use of funds. take the
capital that you raise, build the
prototype, say three months to market,
um $50,000, a little less than 50,000,
maybe a little bit more than 50,000 if
it's got real complex features or
security or things like that that need
to be developed or you know multi- uh
application like you know iOS app,
Android app, web app, desktop app. If
you have to have all those things, you
can basically add 10 to $15,000 per
integration that you need to add. So you
can kind of plan those features and plan
what needs to be built based upon that
model. Again, you can take that, put it
into chat GP03 and say, "Hey, if I
raise, you know, $50,000, what would be
the best use of money to get this
product closer to market?" Right? So we
use that a lot. Use the rest of the
capital that you have left over. So say
you raise $250,000, 50,000 of that goes
towards building out the product. The
other 200 should go towards paid ads or
other marketing influencer content
things like that. You should be creating
marketing materials. Again, I cover all
this in great detail in our course that
is inside the AI course. The prototype
is in the prototype course, but this is
in the AI marketing course. I go through
this in great detail at macansacc.com.
You can hop on there. drive clicks to
high converting pages for demos or
orders. So if the order is say less than
50 bucks per month, you can just drive
them right to an order page. They can
sign up and um you know pay for it right
there. If it's an expensive software,
you might want to do demos uh and do
that. Start scaling your ads. Move over
to a priced valuation round. Again,
consult your attorney about fundraising
and all of that. But once you do have
paying customers and it starts scaling,
it's time to do another capital raise on
a valued round. So say you raise
$250,000 on a $10 million valuation.
Then you can move into depending on the
valuation of the company, use a fair
valuation based upon your forecast and
all your models. Let's say it's a $50
million valuation at a priced round.
Then you can raise some additional money
from VCs or private equity or you know
people that uh are in the industry,
experts in the industry or you know
people that you know people network
through people, talk to people, talk to
me, we can talk about things but point
is you move very very quickly with this
plan and you can move quickly but again
it all goes back to is the problem
you're solving worth solving? Is the
target avatar the right target avatar?
Are you putting these pieces together?
Do you have a good total addressable
market and a serviceable addressable
market and your share of market? Like
are those numbers right? Like all of
these pieces come into play and it might
make sense to have a mentor or somebody
like me to help you. But point is all
these pieces do come into play to make
sure that you are on track to building
something correctly. You can use chat
GP03 for some of this reasoning but
perhaps a mentor uh definitely an
attorney but would help you move a
little bit quicker. So yeah, once you
get the price round, hire scale your
venture and then prepare for an exit in
3 to 5 years. Boom. Done. That's it.
Rinse and repeat. Do it again. Do it
again and again and again and again. Do
it so many times. It's so much fun.
After I had my first exit, I was like,
"Wow, I should just have 10 exits a
year, right?" But I need 10 great
businesses. I mean, I have five right
now, five ventures that uh we're ramping
up and uh taking the exit in the next
three to five years. But yeah, it's I
mean really once you get it down, I mean
this is how wealth is built is when you
do something well one time, go and do it
again and again and again and again. The
first one's going to be the hardest,
they get easier the further you go. So
I'm, you know, couple exits in. It's
getting easier for me. And now with AI,
it's creating prototypes like having
breakfast or having coffee in the
morning, having an app by the time
dinner rolls around. It's insane. So,
there is so much here that I did not
have time for. Sign up at
mattganszac.com for the full course.
You'll get the ideation, the prototype
building, the marketing, and then also
my workshops where I walk through step
by step kind of like I did on the uh one
page that we did. But we do step by step
and uh we have events coming up. We have
a ton of great things. So, if you're
serious about building software, you
really do need a mentor, somebody that's
already had exits, somebody that's
already done these things that can help
move you along. and I will help you to
validate your ideas, plan your software
build and your go to market strategy
inside of there. All students receive
discounts on live events that we have
coming up and our hourly dev work.
You'll get discounts on those as well.
And I will open my rolodex for you as
needed. And you can sign up today and
we'll go deep into each step of this
blueprint and really build this out for
you to have a great business that you
can build and scale and feel really good
about. jump over macanzac.com, sign up
for the full program. You get a discount
signing up for the full program and it's
a onetime fee and uh keep updating it
and also um yeah, we'll we'll do all
sorts of good stuff. So, I mean even if
that if you want to hop on a quick call
with me like we can do that, but you
know, my time is pretty scarce with
running several companies. But I want to
help people. I want to help move you
along. I want to look for new great
ideas that people are doing and uh we
might have good synergy with some of my
projects, your projects and let's see
what we do. I want to build great things
and help good people build great things
and uh solve big problems. So that's my
objective. Jump on macans.com. Hopefully
you found this helpful to, you know,
bring some ideas and bring some things
forward. Hopefully it gives you some
ways to get started even before signing
up. And once you do sign up, uh, we're
really going to dive in and do some
amazing things together. So, look
forward to seeing you in there. And, uh,
let's go. Let's build it. Let's make it
happen. All right. See you on the next
video.